FABIAN HERRMANN: A few
weeks ago, we met Ahmadi.
He's 11, and a soft-spoken kid
who loves video games, YouTube,
and basketball.
And we met Ahmadi while
doing some research
on emerging technologies.
So we sat down with Ahmadi
and a couple of his friends
in Ahmadi's dining room.
And I basically just asked
him about the future--
where he'd like to go
and what he'd like to do.
Here's what he said.
AHMADI: I will go to Mars on
a flying gold Lamborghini.
And if I had magic
glasses, I would
wish for them to bring me my dog
and teleport an ice cream shop.
FRANZ BLACH: We've
all been there.
We've all dreamt
about the future.
I certainly remember
being Ahmadi's age
and dreaming about flying
cars and robots that
catered to my every
need, dreaming
about where new technology would
go and where it would take me.
And when you dream of the
future, what do you see?
Do you dream about concurrent
odometry and horizontal plane
detection?
Do you fantasize about hot
words and utterance capture?
Maybe in this group
here today at Playtime,
perhaps, but at the world
at large, probably not.
More likely, we dream
about the places we can go,
the things we can do,
and the people we can be.
I'm Franz.
This is Fabian, and
we are from IDEO.
FABIAN HERRMANN: IDEO is a
global design and innovation
firm.
And IDEO pioneered
human-centered design,
which is a philosophy and
approach towards design which
always starts with
people's desires.
And it's really
the only way for us
how we get inspired about
future products and services.
And we're here today to talk
about how, in our experience,
technology is always the
most valuable when it helps
us actually realize our dreams.
And we really want
to shift the thinking
from what technology is
capable of to what it
enables us, as humans, to do.
And these four
emerging technologies
are on everybody's lips today.
It's like VR, AR,
digital assistants,
and of course, as well, apps.
And if we talk about apps, we're
talking about that kind of app
that you don't have to
download and install.
We will call them
ephemeral apps.
FRANZ BLACH: Now,
these technologies
are becoming increasingly
important computing platforms.
And none of us want to miss
out on the opportunities
they represent.
And some of you may
already be working
with these technologies,
and some of you
may be considering
working with them.
And you may be
thinking to yourself,
I'd like to get involved,
but I don't know how.
And if I jump in and get
involved, what should I build?
What should I make with
these technologies?
And I'm sure you're
all asking yourself,
how does any of this
fit into my business
and how am I going
to make money?
FABIAN HERRMANN: So today
here at Playtime, we
heard a lot about
the capabilities
of those technologies,
about the features,
and how to implement them.
So we are not going to
talk about any of that.
What we are going to
talk about is actually
what are these technologies good
for from a human perspective,
how do they fit
into your business,
and how you can get started,
and of course, most importantly,
how can we all learn
something from Ahmadi
and his golden
flying Lamborghini?
FRANZ BLACH: Now, earlier
this year, Google Play
approached us, and they posed
a pretty great question.
They asked us, what are these
technologies really good for?
Now, we're really
excited by them,
and we know they have
a ton of potential.
But what do people actually
want to do with them,
and how can we help our
developer partners--
and that's all of
you here today--
how can we help them make the
most of these technologies?
FABIAN HERRMANN: And to
answer that question,
we did what we always do.
We went out and
talked to people.
First, we talked to the
people on the forefront
of those technologies--
researchers, developers,
some of you guys
here in the audience.
Because we really wanted
to understand what
the people that are
developing and creating
with those technologies
have been actually thinking
about them.
FRANZ BLACH: And then
we went and spoke
to both users and non-users
of these technologies,
because we wanted to learn
how people imagine these four
things fitting into their
everyday lives, what
their hopes and dreams are when
it comes to these technologies.
And to do this,
we hosted a number
of group research sessions at
our offices in San Francisco.
The same themes kept
coming up, so we're
going to give you a peek
into one of these sessions.
FABIAN HERRMANN: And for
this particular session,
we invited five people--
among them a self-identified
early adopter, a gamer,
and even a complete techophobe.
So just to let you know, if
we do these kind of sessions,
we like to recruit for
the extreme of behaviors
so that we really span the
full spectrum of experiences
with any given subject.
And it's really
important for us that we
have strong, inspiring
opinions and perspectives
to push our thinking.
And as you can see, it's a very
casual, in-person conversation
over beer, so no one-way mirrors
or fancy tracking technology.
Because again, the intention was
not to be comprehensive here.
The intention was
to really understand
what people are feeling and
what they want, what they do,
and why.
FRANZ BLACH: And we
didn't want to get
distracted by some of the
existing platforms or brands
or products.
And so in order to do
that, we created a number
of design exercises that
abstracted each technology
into something that people could
hold, draw on, and use to start
imagining the potential.
Because we found that
if you give something
to people that's too polished,
they'll look for the flaws.
But if you give them
something that's pretty rough,
they can begin to
see the potential.
So let's take a look
at what we did for VR,
the exercise we did for VR.
So to dig into
people's dreams for VR,
we handed out different scenes
that ranged from the mundane,
like commuting on the subway,
to the more fantastical,
like visiting Mars or
flying over a city.
And we told people
to imagine that they
were transported to this place.
And then we asked them, how
do you think you got there?
What would you do there?
Who or what would you
want to bring along?
Who would you want
to communicate with?
FABIAN HERRMANN: And we
also chatted with our group
about AR.
And to access their hopes
for the future of AR,
we did another simple exercise.
We just handed out
this piece of acrylic
to lay over their
scenes and asked
them to draw what
they imagined seeing
through those magic glasses.
That's how we called them.
Here's what they came up with.
And when we play this
video about AR and VR,
please pay close attention
to what are their wishes.
Listen to what they're saying,
but also what are their desires
and wishes implicit
in their words.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I'm underwater scuba diving.
- I am in downtown Tokyo.
- I am on the New York subway.
- I'm currently skydiving
over San Francisco.
- I was in a meeting,
and I was really bored,
so I decided to come to Mars.
- I'm probably with
my seven-year-old.
- This guy looks like he
could be a famous rock star,
and it would be really cool if
I could validate that somehow.
- My magic glasses allow
me to share this experience
with my followers in real time.
Over here, we have
the donations that
are coming in live as my
viewers like what I'm doing.
- So here you see
a notification.
Lena wants to join
me on my quest
to find the Mars treasure.
- My magic glasses
have two modes.
One is all about me, and
one is all about them.
As for the me mode,
it would show me
recommendations and news feed.
And then for them, I would
be able to understand
how my fellow commuters are
doing, what they're thinking,
what they're feeling,
and what they might need.
- Here in the
corner, you can see
that I have a countdown
to when my pizza arrives
in the real world.
- And in fact, I
would want the ability
to almost dismiss all of
it and like better immerse
myself in the environment.
[END PLAYBACK]
FRANZ BLACH: So Nicky wanted to
bring her kids along with her
to Tokyo, and Angela
wanted to find out
about that potential
rock star in the subway.
And when we hear
Susanna say that she
was in a boring
meeting and escaped
to Mars to find hidden
treasure with her friend Lena,
we listen to that story.
We don't tend to fixate on
whether her VR headset is going
to make her nauseous
or how she's
going to be able to pick up
Martian rocks using motion
controllers.
FABIAN HERRMANN: And
don't get us wrong.
Sure, we know that all
those technical constraints
are important.
But what people
are actually saying
is that they want to escape
to an exciting place,
they want to explore this
place on their own terms,
and they want to share their
experiences with friends.
So at its core, for
us, the promise of VR
is the ability to take
us to amazing new places
with new abilities that are
only limited by our imagination.
FRANZ BLACH: Now, we
heard from another person
that they were playing "Pokemon
Go" during their commute.
And in doing so,
they began to notice
all these wonderful
architectural details
in the New York subway
that they'd missed before.
If you think about that
story in the context of AR,
and if you go beyond the
surface, what people want
from AR is to learn about their
surroundings and the people
within them.
So in other words, the
overarching promise of AR
is that it gives us the
ability to reveal and interact
with hidden layers
of information right
within our physical
surroundings.
FABIAN HERRMANN: OK.
Now let's look at
digital assistants.
And to uncover thoughts
on digital assistants,
we did another very
simple exercise.
We just asked the group
to basically write
a job description for
a real life assistant.
And we asked them, if you
would have this assistant, what
would you ask them to do?
Which kind of skills
do they need to have?
I think most importantly,
which kind of relationship
do you want to have
with this assistant?
Here's what they said.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I'm looking for somebody who's
very organized, a self-starter,
able to predict my needs.
- Be able to keep
my kids entertained
without screen time.
- I would say think Tony
Stark and Pepper and Iron Man.
She knows what he needs
before he needs it.
- And I would definitely
look for a willingness
to challenge my ideas and
propose new or novel solutions.
- Keep me on track
and honest with a lot
of my personal goals.
- If they could show me a
funny animal video every day,
I would be very happy.
- The unusual trait is that
this person never, ever sleeps.
[END PLAYBACK]
FRANZ BLACH: So people
wanted the assistant
to go far beyond just simple
task automation or delegation.
They wanted their assistant to
inspire them, to motivate them,
to keep them honest,
and to make them laugh.
In other words, what they
wanted their assistant to be
is to be very personable.
And they wanted to interact
with them in very human terms
through natural conversation.
FABIAN HERRMANN: So if we
think about digital assistants,
we really need to think
about their potential, which
is that they can support us
in very empathic and very
intuitive ways.
So they can respond to
our mood, to our context,
and sometimes even
challenge and surprise us.
So the promise of
digital assistants
is to be able to control
information in a very intuitive
way through conversations.
And we're very
excited about what
that could mean for
conversational interfaces,
and especially for the
expression of personality
for this technology.
FRANZ BLACH: Now, finally,
we're going to talk about apps,
a subject you're all
very familiar with.
Now, the introduction
of ephemeral apps
prompted us to revisit
how people approach
apps in the context of
what they want to do,
not just how they want to do it.
FABIAN HERRMANN: So we
basically presented people
with two scenarios.
One was a new cafe opened
near your workplace,
and you want to order
something there.
And the second one is you
have to park a car in a city
that you haven't visited before.
And again, we just
asked them how
they would do this in
an ideal world, what
are the challenges coming up,
and how they would go about it.
Let's take a look
at what they said.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I would like to pull up
some sort of interface that
will just magically show up and
have a level of social proof
or validation that this
cafe is actually good.
- If I had a coffee around
a specific time of day,
it should just ask me, do you
want me to order your coffee?
- I would like to at least do it
with minimal human interaction
and with as few
steps as possible,
so things like payment
information is already saved.
- What would be nice
is some sort of alert
or my assistant
telling me, hey, you
know what, it's 10 minutes
past the time you're
allowed to park here.
Don't park here.
There's another spot
10 minutes away.
- It will just automatically
detect when my car has parked
and then when I've
actually left.
- I think what I
would want to do
is I want to pull up and
have my car let me out,
and then it would drive off.
[END PLAYBACK]
FRANZ BLACH: Don't make me park.
And behind the future that he
imagines, really, is a request.
And the request
is that he doesn't
want to deal with the
task of parking his car.
He just wants to
get on with his day.
And you heard another person
say that he wanted to order food
from the new cafe with
minimal human interaction
and with as few
steps as possible.
What he's really saying is just
make it easy and simple for me.
FABIAN HERRMANN: So if we talk
about ephemeral apps, or about
all apps, for that
matter, people
aren't really that interested
in which platform or service
they're interacting with.
They just want to do what
they do when they need to.
And it should be as
simple, delightful,
and intuitive as possible.
And to be fair, that has been
the promise of apps all along.
FRANZ BLACH: Now, we had
one more group session.
This one was with kids.
You heard from Ahmadi
and his Lamborghini right
in the beginning.
We held a session with a
group of kids aged 10 and 11.
And we spoke to them about
the four same technologies
and their dreams
for the future when
it comes to these technologies.
We did the same for design
research exercises with them
with one exception.
Instead of a human assistant,
a personal assistant,
we asked them to design their
very own personal robot.
Because, well, hey, why not?
FABIAN HERRMANN:
And again, we didn't
look for inspiration
from kids because they're
going to be the core demographic
of what we're doing here.
But we asked kids because
they have the ability
to imagine and dream
unhindered of any constraints
of technological or
historical baggage.
And they really did.
So let's see what they imagined.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- This is a [INAUDIBLE].
It has stretchmarks
on its legs because it
can be as small as fitting your
pocket and as big as a human.
It makes gummies for
me in its stomach.
It rests underneath my
bed, and it's my alarm.
- I was transported
to Tokyo, Japan.
And I got here by
taking my private jet.
I'd like to bring my robot, my
friends, my family, and tons
of other things, including
a device that I imagined
that would be a translator
that I would put in my ear,
and it would translate Japanese.
[END PLAYBACK]
FRANZ BLACH: So what does
all of this really mean?
I know cute kids and all.
But what did we learn at a
high level from our research?
Well, if you take a step
back, fundamentally,
the promise of
all new technology
has always been to expand
our abilities as humans,
to enable us to do things that
we weren't able to do before.
So it's never just been
about what the technology is
capable of, but more
importantly, it's
been about what it enables
us to do as people.
And that's a very
important distinction.
And these four technologies
we've been speaking about
give us fantastic new abilities.
And I think that's why we're
all so excited by them.
But sometimes when we're
exploring the features
and specs and capabilities
of these technologies,
we can lose track of what they
actually, fundamentally mean
for people.
And we can get frustrated
by the shortcomings
of the current incarnation of
these technologies, especially
when the frameworks
are still new
and we're all trying to
figure things out together.
FABIAN HERRMANN:
So here's a summary
of the four technologies, and
what they enable us to do,
and what people are
expecting from them.
So VR should transport
us to different places
with new abilities.
Augmented reality
allows us to interact
with hidden layers
of information
in our physical surrounding,
while digital assistants let
us access and control
information and services
through conversation,
and ephemeral apps
make it easy for us to do
what we want when we want.
And again, it's really
important that when
we develop those
technologies that we
keep the human story in mind.
We really need to ask
ourselves if what we are doing
is in service of the desires
and dreams of the people
that we're designing for.
Because if you start
with what people want
and not what's
technically possible,
I think you have
an approach that
increases the likelihood
of really creating
something meaningful,
desirable, and of lasting value.
FRANZ BLACH: So right about
now, you may be thinking,
interesting.
Cool.
That's great.
But how do I apply
this to my business?
How do I apply this
to my particular case
and my customer?
Well, we've got
something for you.
If you reach
underneath your seats,
you'll find a deck
of cards glued
to the bottom of your chairs.
For the people on
the wooden chairs,
they're glued to the legs.
Pop, pop, pop.
It's like popcorn.
All right.
Open the deck of cards up, and
we'll go through them together,
and we'll explain them to you.
So we've called
this deck of cards
human-centered design prompts
for emerging technologies.
And the deck contains 20 prompts
spanning the four technologies
we've been talking about.
And they're there
to help you think
of potential products
in the context
of your own particular
customers' needs.
They're based on our research,
on what we heard people want.
And they're intended to provide
guidance at that early ideation
stage when you're trying to
figure out what to build,
as Ross talked about earlier.
FABIAN HERRMANN: So here's
how these cards work.
You remember
Garrett, who earlier
talked about his magic glasses?
What he really
wanted is the ability
to dismiss everything
and immerse himself
in the environment.
So he's basically
asking for a Mute button
to avoid any distraction.
And that made us think
AR might have the ability
to help people focus.
And that's not typically
what we think about.
When we think about
AR, it's always
about adding stuff,
about augmenting reality.
But what if we use it to remove
things and to enhance focus?
So is there an opportunity to
help prioritize information
in our environment through AR?
FRANZ BLACH: So say you
picked up this card,
and it says, think of a
moment in your user's day
when they're overwhelmed
or distracted.
Now consider your particular
user, their day-to-day life.
And could that be a
certain time of day?
Or maybe it's a certain type
of situation they're in.
You picture that
scenario in your mind,
and then you flip the
card over to the design
prompt, which
reads, how might we
use AR to remove distractions?
So we'll give you an example
so you know how this works.
So say you're a
physical retailer,
and when a customer
walks into your store,
they're faced with hundreds,
possibly even thousands
of different products.
And at times, your
user may be browsing,
and they may just be
roaming the store.
But at other times,
they may actually
know exactly what they want.
And in those cases,
entering a store
may be a very overwhelming
and distracting experience.
So you could consider creating
AN ar application that helps
your customer find exactly what
they want by simply removing
what they don't.
Now, that's just an example.
There's a clear product
opportunity there.
But you can see how there's
a very human desire--
in this case, the
need to focus--
that can be met using AR.
FABIAN HERRMANN: And
what we are doing here
is, basically, we're finding
a design opportunity which
leads with a human scenario
and a need and desire.
So we didn't choose
the technology first.
We didn't say which kind of
AR application can we build?
We basically asked, how
can we help people focus?
And AR might be one
technology that does that.
FRANZ BLACH: And in doing this
exercise, in using these cards,
you may also find
that, actually, some
of these technologies
don't lend themselves
to your business
and your customer,
and that maybe they're
not worth pursuing.
And that's fine, too.
At least by doing
it this way, you
didn't commit months
of resources to it
before finding out the hard--
and, well, frankly
expensive-- way.
FABIAN HERRMANN: OK.
Let's look at another one--
something Susan said about
her personal assistant.
She said she wants
it to make her laugh
and make sarcastic remarks.
So that made us think.
If those digital
assistants should
have really human,
meaningful conversations,
they really need to understand
the mood of the person they're
talking to.
FRANZ BLACH: Or
as Rupert put it,
sometimes I want to have
a discussion with it.
Sometimes I want it to
give me some attitude.
And sometimes, I just want it
to turn off the damn lights.
So here's the
corresponding card.
Think of a moment
in your user's day
when their mood might change.
So consider it.
Is it when they're transitioning
between different behaviors?
Or perhaps they're moving
between different places,
or it's dependent
on who they're with.
You picture the scenario.
You flip the card over
to the design prompt.
How might we adapt the digital
assistant's tone and behavior
to the user's mood?
FABIAN HERRMANN: So let's see.
You're a company that
basically delivers personalized
news via the assistant.
So you can imagine
that somebody getting
ready for work in the
morning during a weekday
wants very different
information and has it
delivered in a
very different way
than, let's say, on
a Sunday afternoon.
And I think it might
be that they want
more inspirational stories.
They want to have
more of a conversation
with their assistant.
And then the question is, how
does the assistant actually
participate in
this conversation?
And the opportunity
is quite literal.
You can give your brand
a voice and personality.
And considering that
your user's mood changes
throughout the day, throughout
the week, throughout the year,
your brand should adapt to that.
And that's, for us,
the only way you
can have a human, meaningful
conversation and also
a long-lasting
relationship with people.
FRANZ BLACH: So those
are just two examples
of the set of 20 cards
you have in your hands.
And we hope you take
these cards and some
of the methods we
shared with you today
and use them as a starting
point to imagining entirely
new products, features,
and potentially even
entirely new businesses
surrounding these technologies.
Because getting started
with these technologies
can be intimidating,
but we believe
it doesn't have to be
complicated or expensive.
FABIAN HERRMANN: Yeah.
We just encourage you to
build those scrappy prototypes
and go out and talk
to your customers.
Because that's the
only way how we'll
find out about their dreams.
Dreams aren't made of specs
and features, SDKs, and APIs.
Dreams are inherently human.
And it's something that's
deep inside of all of us.
FRANZ BLACH: So when building
with emerging technologies,
start there.
Start with the dreams of those
you're actually designing for.
And also, sometimes,
don't forget
to tap into your own dreams.
We're very excited to
see what you come up with
and what you create.
FABIAN HERRMANN: Thank you.